so it's an interesting question will
China pull us out of the economic crisis
and I assumed by us you mean the rest of
the world well without China's
participation in the quarterly bond
auctions of the United States interest
rates would be much higher there would
be more illiquidity in our financial
markets so to a great extent China has
been a force of stability throughout the
financial crisis and providing a buyer
for our treasury bonds in addition to
other OECD countries Japan and Europe 87
are major buyers of us bonds but China
has also been a significant vironment
without that source of liquidity we
would have been in much worse financial
crisis to the extent that china is still
has a huge trade surplus and the United
States still has a huge trade deficit
this capital flow or cycle capital of
clothes will continue where
capital surpluses dollar surpluses as a
result of the trade surplus building up
in the Chinese central bank's commercial
banks will continue to be invested back
in dollar denominated assets as well as
European commodity-based assets in
Africa and Latin America so China is a
large Byron in the world market of
commodities both soft commodities as
well as energy and metals and that will
continue to be a stimulus in those
sectors as well as the financial
stimulus from the purchase of bonds as
far as the Met being a manufacturing
center China obviously has a lower late
labor rate than all being g7 countries
but there are other countries in
Southeast Asia that have are beginning
to compete with China over the last
several years including Vietnam has for
example is a very strong software sector
and that's clearly small compared to
India software sector and the Chinese
software sectors is enormous they're one
of the top five software producers in
the world and his new soft is a one of
the largest software outsourcing firms
in China
the major presence here in Dalian and
they work with many fortune 500
companies helping them save money in
their outsourcing and software
development and maintenance of something
so i think that to the extent that there
is a lot of economic activity and in
china the growth rate is between six and
eight percent depending on the sector
there will be continued to be sector
specific stimulus of corresponding
sectors in the world economy but i think
it's important to rank these sectors by
order of magnitude of stimulus and
recognize that china is both an importer
and exporter capital and an importer and
exporter of commodities and an importer
and exporter of technology for example
solar cells here in Dalian
the solar PV C is being produced for the
world market at very competitive rates
here in deleon so i think it's important
when you ask such a broad question will
try to pull us out of the economic
crisis one has to define which sector
over what time frame and what are the
competitive elements within each sector
for China does play a role either as a
buyer as it as a seller to collaborate
to produce increased economic benefits
for counterparties and so I think this
question is very general and requires
more specificity and let's say corollary
questions in order to come up with a
more scientific answer it's more precise
I know that some people have said yes to
the question that some people have said
no and clearly i think the answer is net
yes that there is a positive economic
stimulus coming from Asia in general
because most of the growth in
the world is coming from asian out
whereas europe the united states are
just coming out of recessions and
economic growth is negative in certain
sectors and positive in other sectors
there's still a lot of deleveraging
going on in the united states whereas
there's been a very high savings rate in
china and they did not have the same
degree of leverage that the united
states and europe had in their housing
sectors and their commercial real estate
sectors and in their banking sectors
there was less there was not as much
speculative excess in China and their
financial markets so I think that when
you survey the economic landscape of
China and analyze the sectors that are
providing economic stimulus to the rest
of the world it's important to
look at the sectors that have the
potential of pulling certain sectors out
of the economic crisis I don't see China
becoming a major buyer of us real estate
in the near future I don't see China
exporting a lot of electric cars to the
United States in the near future I don't
see the RnB being devalued at a
significant rate in the near future if R
& B word devalued that would destabilize
the United States it would also be
stabilized China's portfolio which is
denominated in dollars so the Chinese
have a dilemma and that they do not want
the US dollar to be destabilized they
want to continue to buy
dollar-denominated assets including
Treasury bonds and they want those asset
values to remain stable
measured in dollars are in the exchange
rate so on balance I would say it's a
wonderful question because it provokes a
very important debate but one needs to
disaggregate and deconstruct this
question in order to have a higher
degree of specificity about what sectors
are simulated by Chinese economic growth
and also look at the competitive matrix
of each sector globally and see what
percentage China contributes to imports
and exports in each sector and to that
extent good luck in that research a lot
of that research has already been done
by think tanks and economist focusing on
the us-china us-european us African us
latin american economic bilateral
relationship and i think that is a good
starting point is to look at large
capital flows between china and the
world and look at sector specific import
exports and try to make some deductions
so good luck in that research and again
thank you for tuning in to this Davos
debate